i went to the school of hard knocks and
learned it the hard way
by being on the other end of a bunch of
wrongful termination
lawsuits
[Music]
mark schwartz so great to have you in 20
minute leaders thank you so much
my pleasure happy to be here this is
going to have this going to be so much
fun i'm so excited for the next 20
minutes because we're going to talk
about
how you're on the board of directors of
starbucks and you help them raise their
first institutional funding
we're going to talk about firing without
adverse consequences a class you teach
at claremont if if not mistaken you know
you so you did a harvard mba you went to
claremont before
uh and i'm i'm really really excited
let's start off
back in the day we're at starbucks and
you're getting involved
so um the the process of uh
helping starbucks uh raise uh capital
was not an easy one
um in many perspectives it was difficult
internally um at my investment banking
firm donaldson lufkin generate
i remember going to banking review for
approval of the deal
taking a red eye and there was this one
person on the committee who couldn't
understand why anybody would pay
a dollar for a cup of coffee and
he looked at the first page of the book
and
used the f-bomb word maybe i don't know
30 times
he's going to pay an effing dollar for
an uh
cup of coffee yadda yadda and i turned
to my colleague and said who's going to
tell him it's a dollar fifty
um and um basically
um i uh managed to
um walk into tony james's office who's
the vice chair of blackstone and told
him that
look tony you're on the board of costco
and jeff brotman is mentoring howard
schultz
it's 6 30 in the morning out there call
him
and tell him we're not gonna do the deal
and
tony said okay just get the deal done
and i said what about banking review and
he said um
he just had it um and then the other
issue
was um the company had just
opened its first store in chicago which
was out of the pacific northwest
and it wasn't going well and the key
learning and lesson from
opening new stores in a new territory
is just like the expression all politics
is local it can be said that all retail
is local and so the consumer behavior
um in seattle wasn't necessarily the
same as the consumer behavior uh
in chicago uh people didn't stop
in the winter in chicago even though
400 000 people walked in front of the
store
and ultimately they closed the store
um wow we did we did get the uh funding
done
we um actually raised 30 percent more
than um we were going out for
probably could have done um even more
than that
uh we did it at a slight uh discount to
our offer price but the good news is we
raised more capital
um than we needed and we got the deal
done
and i think the most important uh issue
in
um raising capital at any stage
is getting the capital it doesn't matter
um it's a pretty binary either you got
the money or you didn't
and um so we were able to get the money
and uh move forward and then i got to
serve on the board
which was a fascinating experience
because
i was a young investment banker and i
learned
more than i contributed mark
unbelievable did you realize did you
have the slightest
understanding that starbucks is going to
become what it is today
i knew that howard schultz was a unique
um executive and entrepreneur
even though a lot of people couldn't see
that
i i think he had a certain charisma
and a passion um that was rare
so um i i i think eventually
it would be successful
um you know they um
um it it it wasn't um
always a great success but
i think he um was an unbelievable
student
one best people on his team
and was just fearless about going after
something
amazing amazing okay mark so i i i
wanted you to take me
a little bit throughout your different
because you also co-founded the largest
u.s
hispanic supermarket and you are now
teaching class about
how to fire without adverse consequences
so tell me a little bit about your life
about what drives you and your passion
and then let's move on to firing because
it sounds like something that
every ceo needs to really hone and it's
a lesson that i'm gonna have to learn
either the hard way or the easy way i'm
gonna choose the easy way through this
talk
so um
it was through the starbucks connection
that
um i got introduced to somebody who
became my partner
in um founding bodega latina the
hispanic supermarket company
um jamie shenan introduced me to al
lujan
and we worked kind of as a side gig
on on this and then when it was getting
very difficult to have fundraising
meetings
only in the evenings and on weekends and
seeking a few in
um i decided to take the big plunge
i was definitely inspired by howard
schultz
in my own entrepreneurial
journey i think the training i got in
investment banking was excellent but
there was
something about being an entrepreneur
that was
liberating and that was a great
experience
um that i think
i really wanted to to have right
so so if you didn't just have it an
entrepreneurial experience but you've
co-founded
one of the you covered the largest u.s
hispanic supremacy what what what size
did it get to
just to um three over three billion in
revenue
easy just just three billion just
another entrepreneurial experience but
mark
most importantly let's jump into this
firing without adverse consequences
what is that about why are you teaching
a class the entrepreneurial finance
about
firing without consequences
so um at my alma mater claremont mckenna
college i serve
on the board of the center for
innovation
and entrepreneurship and often at
meetings
um students would come in and pitch us
for
funding for their i uh their business
um or their app as i would call it and
to sort of diffuse by the way when did
when did it transition from business to
app
around what
in most cases it never did in my mind
i i got an app and i want money uh
okay um is do you have a business um
so oftentimes what i would do um
you know these were students in their
you know
19 20 21 years old and
they were good at creating an app but i
don't know that they had any idea or
concept of managing a business and
building a team etc
so i would use this question uh
as a way of sort of um
really kind of separating um
from the shaft i'd say tell me about the
last
two people that you fired and how that
went
and i get a deer in the headlights
response right
oh don't worry um you probably took that
course uh in college and again
uh there isn't that course so you
couldn't have taken it
and i i did this a couple of times and
then i think what
the tipping point for me was a company
that i
had invested in and uh a founder that i
was mentoring
um sent me an email saying you know on a
friday afternoon
saying i'm thinking of uh firing my
co-founder
do you have any tips and i thought that
was such a broad
uh expansive question it's like
i want to be an entrepreneur right do
you have any ideas of a business
that i i could be uh the founder of i
like the analogy yeah
and so what what i did was i put
together kind of
a resource list based upon
my own education so i too did not take
that course i went to the school of hard
knocks
and learned it the hard way by being on
the other end of a bunch of
wrongful termination lawsuits
so i put together this um
uh lecture on how to fire without
adverse consequences
and then ultimately i repurposed it for
a school of non-profit management
and i wrote a case a case study
uh based upon a non-profit organization
that i was
involved with and the firing of the
executive director
and change the name so would be
fictitious right
and you know a couple of the key
takeaways
uh from that first of all
again all politics is local
all employment law is state specific
so you have to know the laws in the
state
in which you are operating and the state
in which you have
nexus which today is kind of almost
impossible as you have employees
scattered all across the u.s
let alone all across the world and we're
just transitioning
to accelerate to even more of that right
right but but
ultimately um you know where the company
is headquartered and
um is is more than likely to be
um the domicile of where the state law
applies regardless of where the employee
is physically um located
right but it is a legal process and the
law changes
and so you need to have um you know the
expertise of an employment lawyer
and the second thing is when you go
into the termination agreement
process um i i i say you need to do at
least two things one
you should be scripted so that it very
apparent
that you are reading from a script and
there
isn't any deviation and second
of all you want to have a witness
on your side so it becomes a two on one
um yeah well i wanna i wanna dive deeper
into these two things
and i'm picking up my computer because
it's making some funky noises
so i'm taking care of in the meantime
but
taking you're saying two on one i mean
you know i'm thinking about myself
coming into a termination room where i'm
about to be terminated
and i have two people reading out a
script to me that doesn't feel very
personal
it doesn't feel like they care about me
too much
uh it's actually designed to minimize
the um litigation fallout okay
okay and as the employer um
that's what your concern what am i doing
in order to prevent the wrongful
termination
lawsuit and um all of
the um you know issues that you're
talking about
um are dealt with um prior to this
um you know i i look at um
firing as a mutual liberation
some employee is not living up to their
highest
and best potential in this organization
you are doing them um a career
favor by parting ways because
you don't want them to be a sub optimal
or
sub performer when they um could very
well be
much better in a different environment
in a different job
you know depending upon the
circumstances and then you don't
want to have the sort of nasty
um you know periodic um performance
reviews that you know basically
don't do anything but cast a paul of
doubt on
employee so in some ways termination
is you know the human way to end
suffering on on both parts i mean
one's very very rational when you put it
that way but i'm guessing
i think that is it also with the
responsible of the ceo or whoever is
managing the termination
to make that clear because right now you
know especially as we saw in kobet a lot
of
large corporations the way that they
dealt with their termination and that's
you know what's in the back of my mind
it was there was you know a whole
variety on the whole spectrum of how you
deal with termination
a lot of them were accused of wrongful
termination a lot of them were praised
for their
for their termination tactics so what's
your take on that
so you know every every situation
is different um and the law uh you know
is different depending upon the
circumstances
most of what you're talking about during
covet 19
would likely fall under what's called a
reduction in force
okay um some of it was a furlough
where um they were still getting
benefits but they were getting
uh they weren't getting any um salary
right um you know i'm talking about a
individual who's not performing and
um you've taken a lot of necessary steps
to try and improve that performance uh
performance improvement plan and it's
it's very clear
it's just not um working
you know my experience
is when it comes to firing or
terminating
um you want to um
fire uh fast and higher slow
most companies flip it around they
um take forever to hire someone
um uh um and um
you know the the the firing i'm sorry
they're very quick to hire
they hire everybody and they fire right
right and then they're um
and then they're slow to fire you you
want that
you know what i say is um
when do you know it's time to terminate
someone
um 30 days before you got the first
notion
in your mind it's it's sort of like um
in my experience um it doesn't get
better
it drags on it gets worse um
have you been involved with how like if
you if you could just you know estimate
over your career
how many firing dilemmas situations
would
were you somewhat of a pardon oh
probably dozens um where i directly
you know went in and handled um
you know the termination and and so on
so you've seen it all you've seen the
good the bad the ugly
and okay wow is there a specific
is there a specific occurrence that you
know sort of list like light switch went
up and
went off and said like wow like this is
there are lessons to be learned about
firing when you're giving it so much
weight
yeah definitely i mean um if you've been
through
a wrongful termination lawsuit and seen
how much time and expense can be
uh taken um to sort of uh patch together
a termination that didn't work out
um you kind of realize that this is kind
of an
ugly side of business and
you don't want to you want to avoid this
as much as possible
no no i'm sure i'm sure mark i'm going
into my own journey now my own
entrepreneurial journey
and i could only wish for myself that i
get you know half of the
incredible experiences that you've had
and we didn't even mention that right
now you're still sitting on on
on quite a few boards right on on some
on the incredible companies one of them
is 129 year old pharmaceutical company
uh pharmaceutical retailer in seattle
bartel
uh drugs yes it's older than nordstroms
and general electric
unbelievable unbelievable so you're
still very very active but
i want to use the last minute to get you
know
one or two key pieces of advice that you
would have for me as i'm entering my
entrepreneurial journey
so um i i would talk about um
finance and raising capital and um i
think one of the most important lessons
i learned the hard way from my own
entrepreneurial journey and what i try
to impart to entrepreneurs
as either an investor or a mentor or
advisor is
make sure you raise enough capital okay
and so
in my hispanic supermarket company
we didn't raise enough capital in our
first round of financing
and i thought we were going to be able
to
secure some equipment leasing or
equipment financing for the store
and we weren't a credit where the tenant
or uh borrower to be able to do that
and we required the personal guarantees
of
all of the investors had we raised
enough capital so we could have just
purchased it outright
and not had to finance it you would have
been in much better shape
and as a result of that experience
um myself and my co-founder
lost some of our equity um when
we sold the business and we had our
liquidity event
you know that equity um was was
worth substantial amount and it just
reinforced the issue if we had
raised more money um might have had
some of that equity very very
fascinating mark
right before we leave i want to thank
you again for all these inspiration and
and and i look forward to maintaining
this relationship and continuing to get
advice from you definitely when i start
my own company
i have it sounds like i have an infinite
to learn but
before we leave i need three words from
you that best describe you
i'm a finance and um
operationally oriented um entrepreneur
uh and board member and what
and board member wonderful mark tadaba
thank you very very much
have a great day and shabbat shalom
shabbat shalom and
thank you michael very much it was a
pleasure and good luck to you in your
entrepreneurial journey
thank you and we didn't even get a
chance to talk about how we're both at j
ventures and
and how and how much fun i've been
having there and and your amazing
contributions to the fun so so thank you
for that too
of course and say hello to our friend oh
dad i definitely will thank you take
care
all right take care bye now bye bye